this man has been a hero of the american
people
for much longer than he's been vice
president he was a the 50th governor of
indiana he was in the house of
representatives for 18 years or 12 years
and he was our 40 is our 48th vice
president help me give a good old
georgia welcome
to vice president mike pence
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
let's move on
well hello georgia
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all for coming out it is great
to be back
in the peach state
[Music]
and it's so good to see so many friends
out on this beautiful day
would you join me in thanking former
governor sunny perdue
[Music]
the state gop chairman david shaffer
[Music]
my friend ralph reed
george's own nick ayers
jenny beth martin ginger howard
all the great georgians who are here
today it is wonderful to see so many
good friends out
and speaking of friends of mine allow me
to bring greetings from another friend
of mine
and a man who's been fighting every day
for the people
of georgia and the common sense values
that have made this state great i bring
greetings from the 45th
president of the united states of
america
president donald trump
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
i'm here because i stand with president
donald trump
[Applause]
and i'm here because president donald
trump
and i stand with senator david perdue
and senator kelly leffler
[Applause]
so thanks for coming out today you know
the president i couldn't be more
grateful
for the support of the people across the
state of georgia over the past four
years
and over the past two weeks
you know it's amazing to think already
president trump has received
more than 73 million votes across this
country
10 million more votes than 2016
and the greatest share of minority votes
of any republican candidate for
president in 60 years
and i can tell you i can tell you as our
election
contests continue here in georgia and in
courts across the country
i'll make your promise we're going to
keep fighting until
every legal vote is counted
we're going to keep fighting until every
illegal vote is thrown out
[Applause]
and whatever the outcome we will never
stop
fighting to make america great again
that's why georgia and america
need david perdue and kelly lefler back
in a republican majority in the united
states senate
for all we've done together for all we
have yet to do
we need the great state of georgia to
defend the majority
and the road to a senate republican
majority goes straight through the state
of georgia
are you with me
[Applause]
you know the president wanted me to be
here today
because we need georgia to send these
two great senators back to a republican
majority
first because of who they are
second because of all we've accomplished
and because the republican senate
majority could be the last line of
defense
for all that we've done to defend this
nation revive our economy and preserve
the god-given liberties
that we hold there
it's true
[Applause]
but i'm here because first and foremost
of who they are
like a son of macon after high school he
enrolled at georgia tech
paid his way through college by working
warehouse and construction jobs
eventually worked his way to the top of
the business world
he spent more than 40 years as a captain
of industry
one of the most respected business
leaders in america
but following his deep conservative
convictions
he answered the call to service and i
can tell you firsthand
that he's been one of the greatest and
staunchest allies
of our maga agenda in the united states
senate senator david perdue
amazing man made georgia proud
and also like another incredible leader
is with us here today
fourth generation on our family's grain
farm here in georgia
build her own company up from the ground
she broke barriers
in business and sports and entertainment
to become one of george's most
successful business women
she has stood strong for conservative
values and already emerged as one of the
most important voices
in the united states senate we need
david perdue and senator kelly lefler
back
in the united states senate thank you
kelly
[Music]
[Applause]
so i know you're out here today for the
same reason i am because of these two
extraordinary people
but we're also here because of all we
accomplished together with their support
and under the leadership of president
donald trump
i mean think about it four years ago we
inherited a military that had been
hollowed out by devastating budget cuts
an economy that was struggling to break
out of the slowest recovery since the
great depression
terrorism was on the rise around the
world
and we witnessed a steady assault on our
most cherished values
but under the leadership of president
donald trump
with these strong allies in the senate
we rebuilt our military we revived
our economy we secured our border
stood with law enforcement and fought
for life
and liberty and the constitution of the
united states of america
[Applause]
you know it's amazing i'm some of you
may not know that actually we're a
little bit of a military family at the
pence household
i'm the proud father of a united states
marine
[Music]
[Applause]
and one of my unworthy son-in-laws is a
lieutenant in the united states navy
and we're proud of them both
and i couldn't be more proud to be vice
president to a president who
signed the largest increase in our
national defense
since the days of ronald reagan
with the strong support of senator david
perdue
and senator kelly lefler we're finally
giving our soldiers sailors airmen
marines
coast guard and space force the
resources
and the support they need to defend this
nation
it's not just been about those who serve
in the uniform it's been about those of
you who did serve
in fact i expect in this great patriotic
state there's many
men and women among us who wore the
uniform would if you served in our armed
forces would you mind just raising your
hand and giving us a chance to say thank
you one more time
thank you for your service
thank you for your service
thank you for our freedom
i love you too you know under the last
administration
i don't have to tell our veterans we saw
years of scandal
at the va that shocked the conscience of
the nation
but president trump was strong allies
like your two senators
he signed the most sweeping reforms of
the va in 50
years we fired more than 10 000
employees at the va that were not giving
our veterans the care
that they earned and now veterans choice
is available for every veteran in
[Music]
america
and every step of the way we have the
strong support
of senator david perdue on the senate
armed
services committee and senator kelly
leffler
on the veterans affairs committee thank
you for standing with those who served
and with that renewed american strength
over the last four years we've stood up
to our enemies and
stood with our allies as never before
under the direction of this
commander-in-chief
the armed forces of the united states
took down the last inch of territory
under the black flag
of isis and captured and killed
their leader without one american
casualty
[Music]
we stood up to iran got out of the iran
nuclear deal
and an iranian general responsible for
the death of hundreds of american
servicemen
qasim salamani is gone
[Music]
[Applause]
so we've stood up to our enemies we've
stood with our allies
and it was this president with the
strong support of your senators
who kept the word that four of his
predecessors has made
to the american people and our most
cherished ally
when he moved the american embassy to
jerusalem
the capital of the state of israel
closer to home over the last four years
after the slowest recovery since the
great depression
strong allies like your two centers
president donald trump revived our
economy
we cut taxes across the board for
working families and businesses
we roll back more regulation than any
president in american
history we fought for free and fair
trade we unleashed american energy
in our first three years we saw seven
million
jobs created and unemployment at a
50-year low
[Music]
[Applause]
and through this year this challenging
year through which we passed
with that strong foundation in the
with the relief efforts that senator
perdue and senator leffler supported
we've already seen more than 13 million
americans go back
to work the great american comeback is
underway
the truth of the matter is
we've had the strong support of these
senators every step of the way
when it came to our security when it
came to our prosperity
but also that's true when it came to the
rule of law
and with the support of your senators
president donald trump and i have stood
strong with the men and women who serve
in law
enforcement at every level with
president trump
david perdue and kelly lefler we will
always back the blue
and may be of greatest consequence of
all
longest term impact on the life of the
nation sit with the unwavering support
of georgia's two senators
we've seen more than 220 conservatives
appointed to our courts
at every level and they are all men and
women who will uphold the god-given
liberties enshrined in our constitution
like the freedom of religion the freedom
of
speech and the second amendment right to
keep and bear arms
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an amazing group of judges
principled men and women and that
includes
justice neil gorsuch justice brett
kavanaugh
and justice amy coney barrett
and none of that would have been
possible without the support of senator
perdue and senator leflan
in fact let me just say i want to
specifically thank senator leffler she
was the first
senator in the united states to call for
the confirmation vote of justice amy
coney barrett and they both stood strong
with this amazing jurist
you know these appointments to our
courts have maybe never been more
important
because the courts are our last line of
defense
the last vanguard of our liberties
enshrined in the constitution
and in our founding documents
when we came into office you all
remember that we'd seen a steady assault
on our liberties and our cherished
values the conscience
rights of doctors and nurses have been
compromised through bureaucratic fiat in
the last administration
a group of nuns known as the little
sisters of the poor were hauled into
federal court
by the last administration to force them
to compromise their faith
to live under the mandates of obamacare
[Music]
and you all remember when judge amy
coney barrett went through her
confirmation two years ago
and the leading democrat on the senate
judiciary committee
said she was concerned about judge
barrett's catholic faith
she said and i quote the dogma
lives loudly within you
and their allies in hollywood have been
attacking judge barrett's faith ever
since
well i got news for the democrats in
washington
and two democrats that want to join
that dogma lives loudly in me
[Music]
that dogma lives loudly in you
and the right to live and worship
according to the dictates of
our faith lives loudly in the
constitution of the united states of
[Applause]
america
that's why for our liberties for our
future
for all the foundation of values that
have made this country great
we need senator david perdue and senator
kelly lefler back
in the united states senate
[Music]
[Applause]
you know let me also say we were just
talking on the bus a minute ago
beyond all of that over the last four
years
a growing economy a strong defense
standing up for our liberties i couldn't
be more proud to be standing with two
senators
and serving alongside a president who
stands without apology for the sanctity
of human life
[Applause]
so for our security for our prosperity
for our liberties and for life
we need senator david perdue and senator
kelly lefler
back in a republican majority in the
united states senate
we need georgia to defend the majority
on january 5th 2021
you know the stakes in this election
have never been higher
and here in georgia i got to tell you
the choice has never been clearer where
david perdue and kelly lefler stand for
a strong national defense
raphael warnock
and john ossoff
[Applause]
will join democrats in cutting our
national defense to fund their big
government programs
you know democrats couple weeks ago were
already talking about deep
cuts in our national defense
to fund their liberal agenda and rafael
warnock has actually demeaned our
military
and repeatedly defended the anti-semitic
rhetoric
of reverend jeremiah wright
and criticized our most cherished ally
israel
and where david perdue and kelly lefler
cut taxes across the board
john ossoff and rafael warnock want to
raise taxes on working families and
businesses large and small
where david perdue and kelly lefler back
the blue
and we'll support conservative judges
and the right to life john ossoff and
rafael warnock support defunding the
police
activist judges and taxpayer funding of
abortion all the way up to the moment of
birth
i heard that uh senator chuck schumer
said
first we take georgia then we change
america
[Applause]
well i got a message for chuck schumer
and all the washington democrats we're
going to keep
georgia and we're going to save america
are you with me
i know the people of georgia get it i
mean our agenda is american greatness
their agenda is american decline
where we're opening up i promise you
they'll be locking down again
remember when they said it was
impossible to have a vaccine by the end
of the year
i got to tell you folks buckle up
before the end of this year we're going
to distribute about 40 million
vaccines all across america thanks to
the leadership of president donald trump
senator david perdue and senator kelly
lefler we're making miracles happen
[Music]
i mean you all get it we just got to
make sure your neighbors get it
every day between now and january 5th
their agenda is higher taxes open
borders
socialized medicine a green new deal
abortion on demand defunding the police
and packing the courts
[Music]
jon ossoff and rafael warnock are
wrong for georgia and wrong for america
[Applause]
so george i got back on the bus today
[Music]
because we need you to stay in the fight
we need the people of georgia to stay in
the fight for integrity
in this election
[Applause]
and we need the people of georgia to
stay in the fight
to defend the majority stay in the fight
until we send david perdue and kelly
lefler back to a republican majority in
the united states senate
so i got a couple things i want to ask
you to do
in the weeks ahead first thing i want to
ask you to do
and i heard that ballots are already
being sent out absentee ballots
just vote georgia
vote to re-elect david perdue and kelly
leffler to the united states senate
[Music]
early in-person voting starts monday
december 14th
and i checked before i got off the bus
you want to make a note of it on the
14th you can go up the road to the
cherokee county board of elections
2782 marriott highway
suite 100
right here in canton
come december 14th they open at 8
30. be in line and vote to re-elect
david perdue and kelly leffler to a
republican majority
in the united states senate
[Music]
may we need you to do everything in your
power
we need you to do everything in your
power
to make sure to just be sure
that your two senators will be there to
be a check on agenda of the radical left
it's up to georgia as we continue our
election contests in courts around the
country i promise you we're going to
stay in that fight
you stay in this fight in georgia
[Applause]
i mean let's show the world let's show
the world
what george is all about
that the agenda of chuck schumer and
nancy
pelosi is not the agenda of the people
of georgia
[Applause]
[Music]
so after you make plans to vote i want
you to go out and tell somebody
talk to your neighbors and friends i
mean we're going into
going into a season here
unknowable season we don't know what the
future holds but
in my house we know who holds the future
[Applause]
but i want you to talk to your neighbors
and friends
tell them what's at stake in this
election tell them why you're so
passionately committed
to making sure that every legal vote is
counted
and tell them why we need these two
senators back
i mean the stakes in this election are
just that high
you know i'll always believe that the
most powerful media in this country
it's not your social media it's not your
major networks it's not your big
newspapers it's not your ajc
it's word of mouth it's when someone who
knows you
and hears from you about a candidate or
a cause that you believe
is important to them important to their
liberties important to the nation
so tell your neighbors and friends that
we've got to count
every legal vote and we've got to
re-elect david perdue and kelly leffler
to the united states senate
you go tell them
and in the uncertain days ahead lastly
i'd encourage you just to have faith
have faith that this president will
never stop fighting
for all the values that have always made
america great
have been making america great again
that built the biggest and broadest
coalition of any republican
in the history of our country have faith
in
these two leaders and all those like
them around the country that have stood
undaunted for an agenda that's made our
nation
stronger more prosperous and more secure
and validate our liberties
and our values and have faith in your
neighbors and friends
i truly do believe that if we if we hold
the banner of freedom high
if we do like those words that are
inscribed on the liberty bell
from the good book that if we proclaim
liberty throughout all the land and unto
all the inhabitants thereof
that the american people will rally to
our cause
because this is a freedom-loving nation
and this is the nation of faith
and finally
in these challenging times in the life
of our nation if you're inclined to bow
the head and bend the knee from time to
time
i'd encourage you to do that too
[Music]
[Applause]
we pray for these courageous candidates
who just finished
a couple of tough campaigns and found
themselves morning after the election
back in another one
pray for our president who gets up each
and every day
to defend the agenda that the american
people elected us to advance
in 2016 and to defend the vote today
and pray for america pray for all the
american people
and when you pray pray with confidence
again in those ancient words from the
ancient texts
remember that if his people
who are called by his name will just
humble themselves and pray and turn
he'll do like he's always done
in much more challenging times than we
live in today
he'll hear from heaven and he'll heal
this land
this one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all so pray for america
pray for all the american people
and if all of us do all we need to do
between now and january 5th
i think we're going to keep on winning
we're going to keep america growing and
men and women of georgia
all of us do our part we're going to
preserve
our heritage of freedom for this
generation and the next
and with your continued support and
prayers
with conservatives elected and reelected
from state houses to the capitol
all across the nation with every legal
vote for president trump counted
[Applause]
and with senators david perdue and
senator kelly leffler back
in a republican majority in the united
states senate
and with god's help
we will keep making georgia and america
more prosperous than ever before
we'll keep making georgia and america
safer than ever before and we will keep
making america great again
thank you all very much georgia god
bless you
god bless america now let's go get it
[Music]
done
[Music]
[Music]
driver
[Music]
look at the problems
[Music]
one kid
[Music]
might be
[Music]
[Music]